we're coming to you from a place that is
definitely Rio de Janeiro and not a
studio across from a 7-eleven in Los
Angeles capitally Rio I promise this is
real I was robbed four times on the way
to Elektra this is a week long @midnight
Tournament that'll be just like the
Olympics and by that I mean underfunded
and on an annoying tape delay we've
scoured the globe for the funniest
people from the funniest countries and
also Germany and brought them here to
attest their wish their humor and their
ability to share one functioning toilet
and now I would like to welcome you all
to the @midnight Olli Bay
unfortunately I can't do that because
the International Olympic Committee sent
out a letter threatening legal action
against non sponsors who read tweets
about the games and any of its
associated trademarks that includes the
words Olympics Olympian and hashtag Team
USA
I can't even congratulate Olympic
athletes on their victories only for non
Olympic things like like for instance if
I saw this picture of a celebrating
Michael Phelps all I could say is
congratulations on your perfect nipples
perfect way despite all these legal
barriers we're still gonna kick off our
tribute to that ancient tradition of
greased-up uncircumcised wrestlers with
an awesome torch lighting ceremony let
the game lack activities starts
happening I feel it
comedians what other things do we have
to do to avoid getting sued by the IOC
Yakov Smirnoff go the Olympics game they
are not supposed to do drugs or take
drugs on this show it's mandatory you
cannot swallow any raw sewage without a
raw sewage swallowing permit and good
luck giving that oh because of
bureaucracy red tape all right boy yes
very good very good
hey Higgins you cannot hire the IOC as
your secretary and then sexually harass
them no you can't do that